if you look at my presidency so far
it's a jobs presidency and it's a small
business presidency while other
countries are stumbling out of this
pandemic we're racing ahead we're in a
position to attack inflation from the
position of strength not weakness
and i believe jay is the right person to
see us through
and finish that effort we are seeing not
just the highest inflation in 30 years
since the president took office it's
actually on par to be the highest
inflation in 40 years in both the
president the speaker and the fed has
gotten this wrong for most of this year
well president biden nominating the
current fed chair jay powell to another
four-year term still has to go up to
capitol hill
but that is not making progressives very
happy that and a number of other
developments let's bring in our panel
fox news senior political analyst brit
hume ben dominic publisher of the
federalist juan williams is a fox news
analyst and trey gowdy former
congressman from south carolina britt
some people were surprised that jay
powell was nominated again
that there might have been this effort
to kind of say that that's a trump-era
appointment and move on but
the markets obviously thought it was
okay
well i think a lot of people were
surprised and and perhaps but probably
relieved as well because
with biden you don't know what kind of a
lulu he might nominate to an important
job like that and i think a lot of
people thought that jay pal had done
well he responded promptly and
forcefully when the uh when the economy
started to crater in the covid shutdowns
and and the pandemic uh flooding the uh
flooding the economy with with cash
now of course we have a problem and the
problem is inflation which was a
potentially possibly a predictable
result of all that in other policies as
well so he faces a challenge of trying
to trying to get inflation under control
and no matter what biden says about you
know we're going to attack inflation
when you attack inflation there's no way
to do it when it's a pleasant experience
for the economy or the people in it
it never has been so this is this is
it's often described as taking the punch
bowl away which is a rather general way
of saying uh that you're going to make
you know money tighter and it's going to
be tough for people so that's the
challenge he faces i suspect he'll be
confirmed elizabeth mar notwithstanding
trey uh
putting the lulu's aside uh
jay powell
obviously has an uphill battle here and
he's
you know some people argued that he
didn't act because he wanted to keep
this job
well you know brett elizabeth warren
said he was dangerous and a failed
leader so i i am struck by how little
influence she has within the democrat
party i mean she openly campaigned for
him not to get this reappointment and he
is but there are progressives like
sheriff brown and others
who have spoken highly of him so given
how bad the comptroller of the currency
a nominee is and she's not going to make
it through
jay powell will make it through and
elizabeth warren's influence continues
to be about the same as the members of
your panel tonight
uh juan
what about progressives and where
they're feeling
they've obviously handed this bill bill
back better from the house uh to the
senate but most including rokhana
expected to come back in a different
version and some are worried that it's
not going to be good enough for them to
pass
well i think the the news here is a
matter of you know
progression that what we know is that
speaker pelosi president biden
the majority leader in the senate the
democrat chuck schumer have all been in
touch as the bill made its way through
the house and now comes to the senate
where joe manchin kirsten sinema those
two senators who have
had some concerns
are waiting but it's not going to come
to them cold it'll come to them as a
part of this larger ongoing discussion
but you know i think it's a very
important point to say here that
president biden clearly is no socialist
he's no
bernie sanders he's not even
elizabeth warren calling for more
regulation of banks to help consumers
because jay powell has been opposed to
that
and so what we get here is somebody who
is like a mainstream centrist status quo
uh nominee the markets went up as a
result and i think what you're going to
see from joe biden going forward and
with jay powell's help
is talk about the fact that this
administration and this
control of the fed has led to five
million new jobs which is a record in
this calendar year he's seen the stock
market grow 25 percent in this year
which is amazing and we've seen gdp now
the forecast is it's going to be five
and a half percent which would be the
most since i think 84.
right and
obviously we also saw inflation and a
31-year high and there are a lot of
people one looking at
joe biden as a candidate and what he
legislatively is pushing
saying that he's far more left than he
was on the campaign trail speaking of
left here is alexandria ocasio-cortez a
congresswoman from new york saying to
new york times there's an enormous
amount of executive action that they're
sitting on that i think is underutilized
on student loans we've got executive
action on the table with respect to
climate there are certainly things that
we can do with immigration frustration
is there and it's part of why the
progressive caucus was holding out on
passing both of these two pieces of
legislation together because like listen
we're not going to take these empty
promises anymore
but you know ben
either is joe manchin as far as what
that bill contains
well i mean it seems to me that when you
look at the situation that democrats
face right now
they're just in this you know ticking
clock scenario where you're not going to
be able to get anything out of
any future congresses so you're trying
to get as much as you can out of the
existing one it's one of the reasons why
the congressional leadership under nancy
pelosi
really didn't care about all these
fights over
you know committee membership and the
like they don't really care what's
happening because they're all headed
toward the exits and when it comes to
you know what what's happening under
their watch
currently they are really just
disconnected from any of the kind of
ramifications politically that they
could be facing uh when it comes to the
midterms because they don't really care
about it anymore and this is the
downside of the lessons that were
learned
under the obamacare experience where you
basically shoved something through
that was unpopular uh without any kind
of expectation that you were going to be
able to run in the future and i think in
this
scenario the same sort of thing is
cropping up under uh the buildback
better plan and everything that's going
to come under it there is no expectation
that you are going to run on this in a
way that's going to support your ability
to come back to the congress
well speaking of running on it brit
the white house confirming that
president biden is planning on running
again in 2024 telling allies that this
says approval ratings are dropping not
only for him but for vice president
harris what do you make of that public
declaration now about 2024 i don't think
it's at all clear that he intends to run
again but i do think that as a political
matter you have to say that
because if you suggest or hint or or
outright say that you're not going to
run again that makes you instantly a
lame duck
and lame duck presidents don't do well
people don't their influence wanes
overnight
so i think this was boilerplate in a
sense but bought a plate that had to be
uttered um i think it's a far cry from
certain he'll run again and he'll be in
any condition too in fact i think the
thing we have to watch is the question
of whether he serves at his first term
he's clearly deteriorating he's clearly
senile and his health is despite his
doctor's claims at the contrary you know
when you're falling downstairs and so on
as he did climbing the stairs to air
force one
that's worrisome
looking live at fort bragg north
carolina there's an event for military
families there ahead of thanksgiving
air force one pulled up to a hangar
there and there you see president biden
and meeting the military members at
fort bragg trey
the
just follow up on what brit said there
about this announcement and the state of
the democratic party that it feels
uh i guess needs to put out that that
now
i have no idea about the president's
cognitive abilities that that's not my
background um
i mean he's always uh had an affected
manner of speech uh for for for 25 years
so i whether he runs um
he may not be alone i mean there are a
lot of ambitious young democrats that
didn't think he was going to be the
nominee this time including his vice
president near as i can recall she ran
although she got the same number of
delegates that that all of us got she
did run
so whether he runs and whether he's the
nominee or two different things